I wouldn't characterize myself as an
entrepreneur I'm I would care to ask
myself as someone who has found a couple
of different things in life that I
believed in with every cell in my body
and this is one of them so you're the
youngest of four brothers including a
couple who became cops yeah well one of
them is is a Mountie works for the Royal
Canadian Mounted Police and the other
one was and is no longer a cop but yeah
my dad was a cop as well okay so how did
you stay alive as a youngest of four uh
you know you get buying your wits if
that's how you do it you don't get
buying your fists so yeah it's kind of
rough household sort of I was less like
the youngest brother but more like a
moving target okay there's a lot of a
lot of that stuff got handcuffed to the
fridge a couple of times the last time I
actually took the fridge door off with
me I was that scared of panic so yeah my
mild we're all super close now but but
when we were when we were kids it was
just every day was in new and amazing
messy stabbing death yeah well how did
that experience prepare you for life you
know it's weird it really did though I
mean it you know when you're when you're
a little kid and you're in a house what
sort of feels like when you're when
you're around people that are five men
basically including my you know my
brothers and my uncle who were always
around it sort of I often felt like I
was walking through some sort of weird
skin covered forest these huge people
everywhere and you kind of become hyper
perceptive you know you start to really
sort of think about how you're gonna
survive so so especially my three older
brothers who were so sort of physical
guys and you know there was just rough
housing like for them was always funny
for me it was like a life-threatening
situation so you sort of you sort of
learned to kind of get by on on using
your mind not your fists so I became
kind of hyper perceptive as a kid and I
know that that contributed in enormous
ways to that different paths I chose in
life you know particularly show business
and that sort of thing I was able to
kind of constantly mimic people or watch
people and look for
any signs and big signs of you know
danger so so yeah that's kind of I think
that's how it shaped me mostly okay so I
read that you were overly sensitive and
nervous as a kid and that you struggled
with shyness and social exam anxiety
about that how bad I still struggle with
those those same things as challenging
as they are and you know they're also
gifts that come with those things you
know and it's that same sort of
situation where you become kind of
incredibly perceptive in ways in which
you you you otherwise wouldn't you know
constantly kind of sensing you know both
real danger and non-existing dangerous
so you're you know that's those are
things that have really helped me in my
work but yeah as a kid it it was uh it
was tough I was yeah I was a kid who's I
had a lot of anxiety a lot of different
kind of phobias and issues that I had to
had to sort of work through and and it
took me a long time to kind of recognize
those things as assets as opposed to
liabilities what do you think it stemmed
from you know it's I think it's you're
standing at that intersection of nature
versus nurture I think there's some of
it was just genetics I was born with and
some of it is circumstances I think in
any household it's hard being the fourth
the fourth kid you know that that's the
kid that's sort of watching and learning
constantly as opposed to the
trailblazing eldest boy or girl who in
any given household so when you
envisioned your life as an adult was
acting the thing that you wanted to do
or was there another career at five or
six years old that you thought about no
I mean I always thought I'd end up as in
law enforcement like my family so I you
know I didn't I didn't imagine that
acting was it was a way to get out of
the house it wasn't really like a
passion when I was a kid it was
something that I was I was already doing
at home you know to survive so you kind
of you know I noticed when I was a kid
making people laugh was a great
self-defense mechanism it really helped
me kind of navigate my way through my
own home with my older brothers and my
dad and I could defuse them by making
him laugh so there was a you know sort
of a kind of a saint for your supper
sort of vitamin house that served me in
great ways later on but bed as a kid it
was that was the means it was a means to
an end it was just a way to get out of
house and yeah I could act I didn't
I said I want to I just knew I could but
specifically improv you had to improvise
and be funny yep
is that what led you into acting yeah I
mean I loved improv comedy I'm never
gonna say that I was the the world's
greatest improv comedian but not
something I've used you know in
countless ways on every movie and every
job I've ever done so I moved to Los
Angeles to to get into improv comedy and
quickly ran out of money and ended up
with an agent getting an agent somehow
and or talking bullshitting some agent
into taking me and then you know ended
up getting a job at show business you
had success as an actor as a kid to some
extent I always characterize anybody who
works in show business as SS as an actor
cuz it's a very tough field but I don't
see you as a steer a stereotypical child
star with stage parents stayed in school
right a hundred percent but I there was
a single soul on earth who would
recognize me from anything in the
showbiz entertainment field that would
make me a star I wasn't a star I was I
was just a kid who occasionally worked
in show business so well what was it
like in high school the fact that you
were doing this acting how did your
peers proceed that I hit it largely in
high school then I never celebrated
always suddenly I kind of really tried
to keep his quiet as possible for me I
school was a situation where I fight the
more invisible I was the more kind of
happy I was so I just wanted to get
through that [ __ ] show and go live my
life it was you know high school can be
a pretty violent crazy place so when I
was as a kid I was always trying to be
invisible so I never I never celebrated
and a lot of the stuff I did was was
shown in the United States but not
necessarily shown in Canada so I could
kind of get away with that
ah I see okay but it laid the foundation
when did you realize that you could make
a career out of acting and as a kid did
you envision that you could get this big
no never I mean I never imagined where I
am today I think I'd have to be kind of
crazy to imagine that maybe not hey I'm
not a big dope residents expect to be
the press I guess right and that's how
they'd probably that's probably the best
way to become a president is to want it
but no everything happened to me sort of
in
by sort of in an aggregate kind of way
it was very slow slow and and steady so
I think I owe that a lot I'm grateful
for that kind of momentum being very
very sort of snail's pace as opposed to
like a rocket ship because I I've
watched so many people in this industry
come and go and in various tragic ways
and that's what thing in Fame is a weird
animal to deal with I think for anybody
so so you know for me it happens so
slowly that it's sort of like getting
into a bath over the course of a year
you know you're not gonna get shocked by
the water be it cold or not you're gonna
you know you're gonna just immerse
yourself in a way that's really really
slow so for me there's nothing meteoric
about about fame or any that stuff I was
able to really kind of assimilate to it
in a way that you know most people
aren't really offered that achill
everything is all or nothing in
Hollywood it's either you're the biggest
star they've ever seen or you're done
yeah you know I somehow found that I got
lucky and found that weird sort of
middle ground where I was able to kind
of just slowly build build my my career
I read that you were actually supposed
to be in college and you moved to LA
without your parents knowing is that
true yeah that's true yeah I I well you
would never tell I would never tell my
father so where were you stopping at a
college I was supposed to be at Kwantlen
University in British Columbia Canada
and I did go there for 45 minutes No and
I left so I was there for a very short
period of time and then I I just thought
I'm gonna go do this thing and I'm gonna
give it a year and if it works great if
it doesn't I'll go back to school get a
degree and go so we're in the workforce
did your parents find out when they saw
you on TV or didn't know it was
essentially tell me it was about six
weeks into my trip in Los Angeles and I
I I called them and said hey I'm you
know I'm in Los Angeles I'm not in
school and then doubt my father hung up
on me and then my mom called me back and
I sort of she was always kind of a voice
of reason and then you know my father
sort of came around after I managed to
make some money at it and kind of get my
foot in the door I think he was much
more accepting of it but any parent
would be like but at that time it was
like I don't know taking a huge risk
like and like I set off a new
bomb was there ever you're not gonna
make it yeah you always think like that
you never lose that thought you know I
just wrapped a film but I've been
shooting for four months and I at the
end of it I thought well this could be
my last so you always get that maybe
that's the thing that keeps you good
right I think so yeah if you get
complacent what kind of screws so you
didn't have a lot of money when you went
to or security when you went to LA but
you did you had your dream yeah what was
the experience like and how long did it
take you two to start to really work I
eventually ran out of money I mean my
family is middle-class family my dad was
a cop and we didn't have you know four
kids we didn't have anything you know I
did everything to kind of lean on in
terms of that so you sort of always had
to make her own way
and I eventually ran out of money so I
just asked that agency to meet with me
and and I called about ten of them and
then I finally got my foot in the door
with one really small agency and i
bullshitted them I just said you know if
you send me out on five auditions I
don't care what they are what they're
for I promise you'll come back with one
if I don't come back with one after five
you don't have to take me I'll leave and
I won't say work is the bomb how I got
the fourth one I got it I got a sitcom
yeah what were the other ones uh the
other auditions were like I think we're
like weird like recurring roles on on
you know hour-long format shows I don't
you know then a sitcom came along which
is like you know a lot of improv and
stuff skills that I had already acquired
so I was able to kind of somehow get
that job when did you consider yourself
a successful actor well that's sort of
difficult I mean I don't you know you I
think I think I can now say that I've
done pretty well in the business I mean
you know um the things like I determined
as a as really successful are things
that you just sort of have to be the
engine on or things that you generate
yourself or okay content you create
yourself or and when that kind of stuff
works sort of like the Deadpool stuff or
in that then I feel like I've really
done something important there's
something at least that's important to
me but I don't know if I ever serve sit
back and think like yeah but what was
that first role where you're you made
real Hollywood money
how much was it well I don't know I
don't remember what I mean I did I did a
sitcom for for four years which was
probably still the best job I've ever
had because it was um the residuals no
no money because it was a live audience
it was like kind of what I wanted to be
doing anyway which was improv comedy and
that kind of stuff it was a live
audience that would pour in and then you
know this sitcom world is about a six or
seven or eight months at most Java year
it is you know you you finish your
season and then you're free so I loved
it because I would just go travel I
would go backpacking all over the world
and I would do all these sort of things
I think I really spent that money that I
made wisely at the time I got to see the
world and have experiences so you know
but back then they don't you know we are
an unknown kind of quantity they don't
sometimes they throw money at you or
anything like that for me it was a lot
more money than I was making driving a
forklift so I was thrilled that you know
I could work six seven months a year and
then go travel for the rest how I how I
did it so I read that you went through
intense physical training to play the
action role as Hannibal King and lady
auntie how did those roles in the mid
2000s help you in your career um they
they helped me they helped me more
personally than they did in my career I
think you know like roles like things
like that we really uh wonder if I could
make it one of those drastic kind of
crazy before and after physical
transformations and I you know it's
given the the resources to do it which
it you know it's average people who are
hanging out at home you don't really
have access to yeah a trainer and a kind
of nutrition program and all these
things that you know I thought were
really cool and I got to serve I got to
check out so yeah that was that to me
was it was fun to set a goal and hit it
you know in that in that regard so it
was less about the professional
propulsion and more about the personal
but all this time Deadpool was in
development right I mean do people
realize that it took 11 years not a lot
of people realize that I mean it's
really as a part of the narrative I
think of the movie though I mean people
who are Deadpool fans know that I was
trying to get this made for almost a
decade
before we got the first one made you're
gonna do a superhero laughing wait for
it
whoa
superhero landing yeah that's really
hard on your knees what were the
barriers why did it take so long well if
you see the character of Deadpool it's
kind of on an unorthodox type superhero
I mean it's a it's r-rated it's you know
it's the character that breaks the
fourth wall he has cancer he wears like
a giant you know red body condom around
I mean these are all like unusual things
for a superhero movie you don't really
ever get to see his face
yeah Studios say well you're casting an
actor you want it we want to see his
face
you know and Deadpool's so much bigger
than a larger-than-life than just like
some some guy who's intermittently
clenching his jaw muscles and squinting
and nice lighting so I for me it was a
it was an opportunity to really kind of
showcase something that I was had been
passionate about for a decade when that
for when I got that first one and I
think this really shows me that you had
a keen sense of business but back then
right especially when the visual effects
footage leaked oh yeah suddenly a
somewhat anonymous person yeah
good-looking but it went Batman's on the
case okay it went viral yeah and and
when that happened the next day they
wanted they said go ahead almost
overnight yeah they they green let the
movie not I mean I think green let it
you know but grudgingly because I it was
something for 10 years I've been trying
to roll this rock up this hill and I
came right rolling back on over me but
but big ROG ingly and I say that just
because they gave us the absolute bare
minimum amount of money that that to
make the movie and it was such a great
life lesson because you know necessity
truly is the mother of invention and you
know dead Deadpool's one of it I think
one of the most interesting IPS out
there because it it really meets that
intersection of you know viral marketing
and sort of like traditional fan
favorite superhero so like there's no
money for anything at some point we was
all joined forces become a team
now how many of you have taken a human
life
what can the size what roles did you
play in addition to actor on Deadpool 1
& 2 producer and writer researcher
writer and I don't worked really close
into marketing with with George Dewey
who's my producing partner now but at
the time worked at Fox and obviously the
marketing team at Fox but so yeah it was
it was it kind of everything you just
sort of wear every hat and and you know
trying to lose your mind in the process
okay
will there be more Deadpool movies how
far do you think the franchise could go
well I think it's like an interesting
world I mean it's there's some there's
so many aspects of that world that are
really scalable to me and I think you
know it's uh there's just not enough
ears or hours in the day for the amount
of ideas that I have and the other other
creators of Deadpool have so we love it
and we have a ton of different avenues
we could go I think I'm just gonna pick
one what's the biggest lesson that
you've learned about the business side
of film and acting mm-hmm in the last
couple years um always just embrace this
idea that you know nothing cuz you don't
I mean I you know as soon as you think
you know exactly what how it's all gonna
go down or or what audiences are really
yearning for you know they it it you can
be surprised you know so I love that
edict I like that idea that I
I believe in film and any endeavor to be
a process of collaboration I think you
always have to listen and always ask for
help and the best leaders are the people
that hire the best people so that's for
me that's that's the thing that I think
that's the biggest lesson I've learned
is like you know just how are the best
people you can people that you connect
with people that you love people that
you know you can learn from and that's
how you that's how you make I mean but
at some point you decided that you
wanted to venture beyond acting and get
into business what made you decide that
well I love marketing
and I love gin so it was kind of a
natural natural marriage okay so that's
a natural segue into aviation gin which
is your company
tell me about aviation gin aviation gin
is a craft sphere at an incredibly fast
growing craft spirit that I have which I
am one of the owners of it's been around
since 2006 it was created in Portland
one of the only it's the highest rated
in the United States which is important
as this quarter 97 and wine-tasting
magazine and it's one of the actually
one of the only spirits that was created
through the collaboration of both a
distiller and a bartender which is if
you think about it would kind of be the
best possible way to create any sort of
spirit to people who are experts in
their field coming together creating the
thing that I think consumers would
absolutely love so that's the aviation
gin in a nutshell or a bottle
we prefer I spoke with Andrew one of
your business partners and he told me
that you were a fan of aviation gin and
just reached out to the company you just
picked up picked up the phone yeah is
that true yeah okay that really struck
me because he said that in the
conversation you called and you wanted
to buy the company yeah I did and I was
probably told I couldn't buy the whole
company like who does that like hey how
are you doing yeah I want to buy your
company oh yeah I know I usually that
sort of ends badly but do you do that
often
no no I'd never done it and it was only
because it was sort of kind of in a
weird way like the same footprint of the
Deadpool story which is that I just
found this thing that I really believed
in and the last time I'd had a feeling
like that was Deadpool so there was a
parallel between Deadpool and this
company there is for me and I'm watching
it happen right now I mean you know I
bought into the company it was a 20,000
case a year business and now it's a
40,000 case of your business and that's
in less than one year what do you
attribute that to
um I attribute that to just exposure you
know anyone who tries it pays basically
switches to that brand so the more
people you can get to try it the better
your businesses and and you lead with I
can never be as great an ambassador for
aviation gin as aviation Jinyan so for
us it's that brilliant intersection of
a product that is better than anything
else on the market and then also
marketing we love marketing and so
marketing aviation Jean has been one of
the most fun endeavors I've ever had
which insights from the film business
have you brought into the Jin business
well I mean non-traditional marketing is
the biggest one um you know I don't and
my partner George and I both sort of
feel like you know paint the paid ad
business is a little tricky these days
and not necessary that that catches
waves the way like you know digital and
viral marketing does and again it goes
back to that same lesson I learned on
Deadpool which is necessity is the
mother of invention we don't have a
marketing budget the way some of the big
massive you know century old gin
companies do ours is tiny and because of
that we have to think out of the box and
because that we have so much more fun
doing it so creating aviation gene
content has been one of the great
adventures of my life it's so he's so
much fun so you have like viral videos
that you're shooting and what other
kinds of things are you doing tons of
viral videos tons of it not tons but
just enough that we feel each one that
we do invest and makes a huge impact I
mean some of the things that we've done
have had way over a billion impressions
and and it's just and we did a video for
sure Branson it was giant we did some
stuff Jimmy found it was it was huge and
it's in its um
some of it is leveraging relationships I
mean I I recognize the fact that I can
get into rooms that maybe you know
unknown guy who owns a gin company you
think it yeah so I you know I definitely
use that to our advantage and I also
make fun of that in our viral videos I
mean our viral videos are hyper
self-aware okay yeah so we often place
me in a position of dum-dum there people
come up to me all the time and they say
what makes aviation gin so delicious
most the time I run away cuz
non-celebrities frightened me you have a
relationship with birds and Airlines
yeah tell me about that that came about
pretty organically I mean you know
Virgin Airlines is sort of like a like
if you're gonna look at it it is an
airline it's also found the Rockstar
airline you know and I think that they
saw aviation Chynn is this incredibly
fast growing spirit and something that
they wanted to be wanted onboard their
fleet and in all their lounges and
sort of thing and we just thought let's
do some something fun about it so we met
with with the the the Virgin team and we
came up with this this pitch with
Richard Branson where I'm sort of
sitting there talking to Richard Branson
and basically telling Richard Branson
that or allowing Richard Branson to
believe that I think we're merging and
he's just a partnership but as a
businessman I know all deals are about
scale scope not the least of which scale
we're even more focused on ROI KPI
Threepio EPS an OMG WTF
run yes sir Richard go easy on the
business jargon
I often love casting myself in a role of
this complete business idiot and that's
super fun so and Richard Sir Richard
Branson is a huge sport about these
kinds of things and he's so he very much
loves laughing at himself as do I so
what's your goal do you want to see this
thing acquired or do you want to grow it
exponentially um I want to grow it I
even no matter what happens even if it's
acquired tomorrow I I'm I have to be a
part of its DNA still so it's something
I truly passionate about so you know
hopefully I'll get to be a part of this
for the next 40 years whether I'm the
owner or someone else would you consider
expanding into other spirits as well um
I probably would but I have to find
something that I really truly believe in
I couldn't just sort of do it I also
don't have time for that sort of things
yeah right and it's not like I mean
could you see yourself expanding into
restaurants and all that or is that too
much I don't know I mean it's just it's
an it's a matter I think you have to
have an authentic connection with
something you don't want to just I just
don't want to beat guy who's just
acquiring crap just to acquire crap I
have to have a really authentic
connection with it otherwise I think you
know the audience the people that the
consumers of whatever that product is
they're gonna know that I don't have
that same sort of fluency with whatever
the product is I have to have a
connection with it if I don't is
important so do you have other
investments or is this your main one oh
yeah I have other other things that I'm
invested in but I'm not the face of or
anything like that what kinds of things
are you excited about I just I get
excited about stuff that's kind of
you know in inventive I love ingenuity I
love anything that sort of I think is
I'm not like a guy that sits around sort
of rolling a dice looking at the stock
market and that kind of thing I don't I
don't know anything anything about that
but with maximum effort Productions is
it's obvious my production company its
we are focused on a lot of different
kind of fun things one thing that's a
huge priority for us is again we're
always like looking to do stuff that's a
little outside of the box and sort of
bucks the traditional system but we
found a kind of a thriller horror story
on reddit believe it or not
reddit no-sleep called called the
patient who nearly drove me out of
medicine which is one of the most
frightening stories I've ever read in my
entire life it's a it's a short story by
80 pages but it's just engrossing in
every way and they're half the time
you're reading you have chills oh my god
her spine so that's something I'm really
excited about just because there's a
completely different Avenue to pull a
source material from which is you know
pulling it basically from another form
of social media which is kind of an
Orthodox and then I think with maximum
effort we're gonna look at we love
marketing so we sort of are branching
out and that in that area yet we're not
at the point we're ready to make some
kind of crazy announcement but it's
something we're passionate about we love
inventive groundbreaking marketing and
that's something that is we're very
passionate about so I'll we'll see if we
if we move the ball down the field there
- what do you want the Ryan Reynolds
brand to represent long term oh man I
don't I think it's got to be it's got to
be quality and and and to some degree
something that is also inspiring and
entertaining and you know and and and
fun and doesn't take itself too
seriously like I don't take myself too
seriously you know you know there's an
old line from a movie that you would
never expect to have that much wisdom
but there's an old line from Van Wilder
which is you know don't take life too
seriously because you'll never get out
alive and it's true I mean that sort of
I've held that with me for you know
almost 20 years now since that movie but
it's very true you know that's you never
you know live so have some fun where do
you have now that people know that
you're invested in this company do you
have a lot of people trying to get a
hole
you and offering you business
opportunities yes it's not so much that
I have a lot people that are trying to
get it in involved in aviation gin so I
feel a lot of those kinds of enquiries
like all can i buy in or can I invest
pretty much that's a good problem it's a
great problem to have I wish I could say
yes to the people but it's a great it's
a great problem yeah in thinking about
your future what's important to you
family 100% as anyone will know it's
almost frustratingly so for some of the
people I work with is that I gotta make
sure that my time is my time of my
family is prioritized over anything else
is it something that you could see your
kids involved in one day aviation gym
maybe yeah I mean I don't you know you
always want to give your kids every
opportunity possible to sort of sample
different walks of life and thinking so
I don't I haven't zero investment in
them doing anything that I'm involved in
be it show business or aviation gin I
just want them to do whatever they want
to do so yeah I prefer it not be show
business and once they're 18 it's like
no show biz go into the liquor watch
whatever responsible parents should do
Ryan Reynolds
[Music]